et bien bonjour à toutes et bonjour à
tous on est en direct sur brut avec edwy
plenel cofondateur à mediapart bonjour à
vous bonjour on va parler de vos
enquêtes justement en pleine période de
crise sanitaire du coronavirus peut-être
avant de rentrer un peu dans l'est dans
les détails il ya cette déclaration du
président de la république hier qui a
dit l'état à partir du 11 mai en lien
avec les maires devra permettre à chaque
français de se procurer un masque grand
public alors c'est ce qui était évoqué
il ya pas repris dans la république on
va donc parler de ces fameux masque qui
sont un peu le sujet qui déchaîne les
passions depuis quelques semaines et
quelques mois maintenant
l'occasion peut-être de rentrer sur la
première question de se dire nous
expliquer un peu votre enquête dans les
grandes lignes et on rentrera dans les
détails ensuite avec les questions des
internautes
à un moment comme celui que nous vivons
qui est un moment sidérant qui est un
moment à la fois énigmatique et et qui
nous interpelle tous c'est un moment où
on a besoin d'une presse qui nous aide à
comprendre
il s'agit pas de révéler pour révéler il
s'agit de donner du sens
le savoir est une arme l'ignorance nous
désarme
il ya quelque chose d'insupportable à
être assigné à résidence confiné chez
nous et en même temps d'être comme
congédié de ne pas pouvoir nous en mêler
de ne pas pouvoir donner notre avis
comme si on était infantiliser comme si
on attendait l'oracle et la messe
présidentielle de ce point de vue à
quelque chose d'archaïque on a un homme
qui parle tout seul et qui décide tout
seul sans nous dire comment il a décidé
et sans nous donner les moyens de savoir
si ce qu'il a décidé est juste ou non
alors du coup mediapart on a fait comme
on fait toujours
on a cherché des informations des faits
des vérités qui nous permettent de
comprendre qui nous permet d'être lucide
qui nous permettent d'être agit d d'agir
et de ne pas être
sife est donc qu'est ce que nous avons
découvert nous avons découvert
premièrement par une investigation menée
par yann philippin antxon rouge et
marchi marine turquie nous avons
découvert qu'en janvier quand la lame
commence à être donnée par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé il
ya une alerte qui est faite au coeur de
l'appareil d'état de la direction
générale de la santé et du ministère de
la santé sur une pénurie de masques
il y avait en france jusqu'en 2012 des
plans avec des procédures très précises
en cas de pandémie avec le strass avec
la grippe h1n1 et d'autres il y avait eu
des alertes au début de notre millénaire
pour dire il va y avoir des pandémies
les virus vous savez on existait avant
que l'homme existe et ils continueront à
exister si notre espèce disparaît un
jour
donc la question n'est pas la fatalité
du virus la question c'est comment nous
l'humain nous nous organisons pour
empêcher que l'émergence d'un virus se
transforme en pandémie et créer une
surmortalité et a fait que nous avons
des proches des amis des parents qui
décède alors qu'il n'aurait pas dû
mourir et donc il y a eu des procédures
qui étaient mis en place avec tout un
plan on a même interviewé certains de
ses responsables
et il s'est passé un événement sidérant
sous le quinquennat de françois hollande
c'est que c'est comme si l'état avait
tout oublié et les choix stratégiques
notamment les stocks stratégiques de
masques qui était en place
pas seulement les masques chirurgicaux
mais les masques qui sont sp2 et sp3 qui
sont des masques tout à fait nécessaire
pour les personnels soignants quart
un des drames que nous vivons
aujourd'hui c'est que ceux qui sont en
charge de nous guérir contractent la
maladie eux mêmes les soignants il y a
beaucoup de soignants qui ont été
contaminés par le corona vidus par le
cos vide 19 et certains même en sont
décédés et donc je reviens nous
découvrons qu'en janvier il ya une
alerte des gens disent catastrophe c'est
le stock de masques stratégiques ont été
liquidés sous la présidence précédente
hélas ce qu'est ce que nous découvrons
c'est que au lieu de dire la vérité au
lieu de dire aux français en janvier
écouter en a un problème il ya une
pandémie qui arrive elle arrive de chine
mais elle arrive
y'en a pas de frontières et je rappelle
que le premier cas en europe de
coronavirus est en france il n'est pas
en italie et bien du coup on vous dit la
vérité il ya eu des mauvaises décisions
qui ont été prises
nous ne sommes pas armés parce que le
masque
c'est la première protection c'est ce
confinement personnelles qui pourraient
pu éviter qu'on soit confiné
collectivement dans des appartements
trop petits les uns sur les autres
avec toutes les tensions que cela peut
que cela peut générer
c'est à dire que c'est un confinement
dans la rue et on se protège et on
protège les autres et je souligne que
par ailleurs et on y reviendra
l'existence des masques et notamment des
masques les plus sophistiqués est
d'autant plus nécessaire qu'il n'en a
besoin pour pratiquer les tests parce
que quand il y a les tests le patient
tous le patient rejette le virus et donc
si le soignant qui fait le test n'a pas
se masquer hyper protecteur il risque
d'être contaminé donc la question des
masques est une question décisive
on aurait pu s'attendre d'un pouvoir
responsables qu'ils disent nous ne
sommes pas comptable c'était la
présidence précédente
nous découvrons cette pénurie eh bien
nous lançons un appel à la
mobilisation générale en janvier
mobilisation générale des industries
mobilisation générale réquisitions
vérité et nous disons que c'est cette
bataille que nous allons mener vous dans
votre enquête c'est parce que vous voyez
à ce moment le choix inverse effet il
est décidé de cacher cette pénurie de
masques et donc de mentir et c'est là
qu'on va jusqu'à ses mensonges énormes
proférées par la porte parole de
l'elysée syb ndiaye qui ne parlent que
sur ordre et qui dit le masque ça ne
sert à rien au mépris de toutes les
recommandations des soignants alors ils
mentent pour cacher cela et en se disant
on va cacher ça pour reconstituer le
stock de masques
mais en même temps ils créent du
désordre parce qu'ils ne disent pas la
vérité et pas ailleurs il faut souligner
que les acteurs le directeur de la santé
actuel ils étaient tous au cabinet de la
ministre de la santé marisol touraine
quand ses stocks stratégiques
à l'époque on était on it et mazars des
instituts voulons reconstruire mais
c'est que c'est jérôme salomon de la
même manière beaux toutous tous les
acteurs tels que pas qu'ils sont là au
coeur de cet appareil d'état était dans
cette présidence précédente et ça
explique peut-être le fait qu'il n'ait
pas assumer cela alors on découvre ça
deuxièmement on découvre que des
industries des industries vont avoir des
passe droit à un moment où on aurait
besoin de tous les masques et notamment
des masques et les plus sophistiqués
nous révélons dans cette enquête que
l'industrie aéronautique et notamment
airbus qui sont fabriqués dans la région
de toulouse où les ouvriers ont ces
masques très sophistiqué fsp deux parce
qu'il ya des substances toxiques pour
fabriquer les avions eh bien il les
garde
ils les gardent et il continue à les
dépenser car ces masques il faut les
renouveler
ils ne font pas on peut pas les porter
pendant une semaine ces quelques heures
est un vrai ils ne sont plus utiles
c'est ce que disent les anciens soit
environ quatre heures donc c'est soit on
faisait au moins et soixante jours c'est
sidérant c'est à dire c'est à dire que à
un moment où l'industrie le aériennes et
au sol voulu le voilà où il n'ya plus
toutes ses communications avec des
passagers ait eu les frontières sont
fermées
eh bien rien n'aurait été plus urgent
que de continuer à fabriquer des avions
au lieu de libérer ses stocks de masques
et de les donner à ceux qui en avaient
besoin c'est-à-dire les soignants or
xavier rognant en détail un peu d'entrer
dans ce film mais il ya notamment cette
question c'est à dire que des gens de
l'industrie a été favorisé par rapport
aux hôpitaux la distribution des masques
au débat et ça se met c'est bien sûr b
c'est une des clés de ce qui s'est passé
et qui continue sans doute l'obsession
économique
l'obsession économie qui a quelque chose
dans l'irresponsabilité de la gestion
tout ça depuis janvier par le pouvoir
qui était la peur que l'économie tombe
la peur que l'économie tombe à tel point
et ça a été trop peu remarqué il ya une
décision qui a été prise qui est assez
sidérante les pays de schengen les pays
de l'espace schengen c'est à dire les
pays européens qui s'occupe donc de la
circulation entre les frontières
le 1er février le 1er février 25 pays de
l'espace schengen européens suspendent
les visas avec la chine sauf un
sauf un la france 25 pays
le 1er février dise on peut pas à faire
comme si de rien n'était pas ce que le
foyer de la pandémie en chine
c'est là où toutes les entreprises
françaises ont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'intérêt
et d'ateliers et du sinn comment se
fait-il qu alors que tous les autres
pays de l'espace schengen décide de
suspendre des visas et que la chine que
la france ne prenne pas cette décision
comment est ce possible c'est pas pour
le tourisme c'est pas pour des voyageurs
landa c'est la logique industrielle
c'est la logique je dirais lvmh bernard
arnault mon business 1 mondial
il est aussi fait avec la chine c'est
quand même sidérant l'obsession
économique que vous avez vues dans
ycompris toutes ces décisions
contradictoires se fait qu'au moment où
est décrétée le confinement on dit faut
quand même aller travailler
je rappelle que dire ça c'est aussi une
injonction aujourd'hui vous savez que
près de 40% des gens qui sont ouvriers
travaillent se déplacent prennent des
risques
il n'y a pas que les soignants de la
décision annoncée hier par le président
de la république qui sidère tout le
monde
il annonce tout seul sans qu'on sache
comment il a pris cette décision le 11
mai il y aura des confinement progressif
mais dit yves les écoles les collèges et
les lycées reprendront et pas les
universités et il dit par ailleurs y
aura ce masque mais on ne sait pas
comment
parce que vous lirez sur médiapart nous
avons aussi révélé qu'à cause de
l'erreur initiale
depuis la france court derrière les
masques et les quatre fabricants
français de masques ne pouvait produire
au début de la crise qu au maximum 10
millions de masques par semaine il donne
aussi besoin élevé mais c'est des
milliards qu'il faudrait puisque lors qu
on sait qu l'heureux leur durée
d'utilité et donc la france du coup
s'étant réveillé tard court derrière
dans la compétition mondiale pour
obtenir ces masques on ne peut pas
croire après ce mensonge initial sur
parole monsieur macron quand il dit le
11 mai vous
ray lema et je continue juste pour vous
préciser ce que je voulais dire sur le
11 mai qui est quand même sidérant et je
souligne que tout d'un coup tient le
conseil scientifique on l'a pas entendu
comment on rouvre les écoles les
collèges et les lycées et pas les
universités mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
alors qu'on n'est pas sûr que la
pandémie soit terminé quelle est la
logique
le médecin français philippe klein qui
était à gwen lab en un an en chine et
qui était au coeur de la bataille il dit
il a dit sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'on ferme en premier c'est les
écoles est ce qu'on ouvre en dernier
c'est les écoles cd kloster les lots qui
est aussi l'idée d'un confinement
beaucoup plus strict c'est celui qu'on
ans est décédé des clusters avec les
enseignants les élèves on a demandé à
des élèves d'écoles primaires de bath
quarts et deux passes touchés ne pas se
parler
c'est impensable quelle est
l'explication logique belle explication
logique c'est aller travailler
c'est que les parents à y travailler il
ya un argument qui dit et qui est vrai
l'inégalité sociale plus l'école est
fermée plus cela pèse pour certains mais
incohérences encore une fois tout cela
est la non transparence de tout cela
c'est d'annoncer cela d'annoncer cela de
ne pas l'annoncer pour les universités
pourquoi pas parce que les étudiants ils
sont pas tous à vivre chez leurs parents
dont encore une fois cette logique
économique cette logique productiviste
je rappelle que tout le week-end nous
avons eu des déclarations du medef est
relayée par certains des membres du
gouvernement sur le thème faut se
remettre au boulot
non il faut d'abord protéger notre santé
ce n'est pas le productivisme qui veut
dans ce moment là va être la clé
essentielle nous arrivons aviv
nous arrivons à nous nourrir nous
arrivons à fonctionner il ya des
solidarités il ya des fraternités donc
c'est qu'une aucune incohérence qui
renvoie au mensonge
initiée le mensonge initial justement ce
que vous évoquez dans vos articles qu'on
peut lire en détail sur mediapart
si on prend peut-être la chronologie
justement défaire charge les sorties
parce que je trouve c'est très
intéressant
il ya un côté enquête d'investigation
qui est le mensonge d'état sur les
masques ça c'est à partir de faits de
documents de mails et y compris je le
souligne à l'époque il est proposé des
stratégies offensives d'achat de masques
au niveau coordonnées européen par
certains certains des acteurs au coeur
de l'appareil d'état et ses balayé on
leur dit si on ne le fait pas si on
prend les événements cette pandémie donc
qu'elle commence les trois premiers cas
en france c'est le 24 janvier 24 24
janvier
les trois premiers cas en france et je
souligne ce sont les premiers en europe
avant vitalité du won en chine dont
c'est en novembre serment sont nova
l'âme et le confinement sous sa forme la
plus stricte commence dans cette période
là c'est à dire mi-janvier fin janvier
et de façon à baisser la chine est un
état autoritaire
il ya une grande opacité il ya eu des
lanceurs d'alerté y compris qui ont été
réprimées qui aujourd'hui sont
considérés comme des héros qui pour
certains sont morts dus coronavirus et
il a été souligné y compris nous l'avons
documenté combien le ms a eu aussi
quelques temps de retard pendant ses
deux premiers mois je dirais de novembre
à janvier liée à de trop forts liens de
la bureaucratie pourrait-on dire
actuelle de l'om est-ce avec le pouvoir
chinois mais en janvier ce n'est plus le
cas ce n'est plus le cas l' oms lance
l'alertent elle lance la lèvre je
voudrais vous soulignez le 24 janvier
trois premiers cas sont recensés en
france que dit la ministre de la santé à
l'époque agnès buzyn le risque
d'importation depuis one est modérée il
est maintenant était modérée il est
maintenant pratiquement nulle puisque la
ville vous le savez est d'isoler les
risques de propagation dans la
population française
centrès
les déclarations de la ministre de la
santé qui dit absence de prise de
conscience publique mais nous savons par
nous enquête qu'au même moment au coeur
de l'appareil d'état au coeur de ceux
qui travaillent là dessus il y en a qui
disent mais non il faut faire ce qui
sera fait l'allemagne pourquoi ça va
mieux
ils ont pris la décision des masques ils
ont pris la décision des tests pourquoi
eux ne sont pas confinés comme nous
parce que l'état a réagi sans mentir et
en prenant au sérieux l'alertent je
continue deux jours plus tard la
ministre de la santé toujours l ami s
busin sur le stock de masques et de
savons aujourd'hui que c'est un mensonge
nous avons des dizaines de millions de
masques en stock en cas d'épidémie ce
sont des choses qui sont d'ores et déjà
programmées si un jour nous devions
proposer à telle ou telle population aux
personnes à risque de porter des masques
les autorités sanitaires distribuerez
ces masques aux personnes qui en auront
besoin
quelques jours plus tard l'om est-ce
déclaré l'urgence de santé publique de
portée internationale le 30 janvier que
se passe-t-il le lendemain
rémy buzy le lendemain le 31 janvier
état d'urgence sanitaire de portée
internationale parle oms et nous sommes
en france dans un pays on le voit où
tout se prend au sommet l'elysée le
château le palais présidentiel le
président est bien la conseillère santé
des manuels magon celle qui coordonne
tout ça à l'elysée marie fontanel le 31
janvier n'a rien de mieux à faire que de
quitter son poste sans successeur nommé
quand même temps son succès 200
personnes pendant un mois
cercle entre fin janvier et fin février
personnes jusqu'au 1er mars
pendant un mois pas de conseiller santé
à l'elysée et pourquoi par terre
adam fontanel pour aller s'installer à
strasbourg où son époux ancien
socialiste comme beaucoup d acteurs qui
entoure le pouvoir actuel et le candidat
en marche aux élections municipales
il aurait été utile que cette dame reste
à l'elysée vous savez quel était son
rôle avant d'être nommé à l'elysée avant
2017 est la vérité l'une des directrices
de l' agence régionale de santé du grand
est
la voix a commencé le foyer pandémique
avec ce congrès d'une 7 rassemblement du
religieux pentecôtiste grand test
elle connaissait et son patron vous
rendez compte le patron il pourrait lui
dire 'attendez tu peux pas partir pour
convenance personnelle alors qu'on a le
dia le feu au lac va attendre
on verra non il la laisse partir
pourquoi je vous souligne ça j'ai
souligné l'aveuglément économique
l'obsession on va mentir il faut pas que
l'économie tombe le taux de croissance
tout ce que nous mettons cause dans
toute cette histoire
notre santé vaut mieux que des profits
quand même nos vies valent mieux que des
profits il vaut mieux de la solidarité
de l'entr'aide que de la compétition et
de la concurrence c'est la leçon de
cette crise mais l'autre aspect c'est le
cynisme politicien les municipales non
seulement les municipales à peut-être
avant d'arriver aux municipales pour
poursuivre un chrono dans la chronologie
on a notamment le directeur général de
la santé donc jérôme salomon qui demande
d'accueillir dès que possible
1,1 million de masques ffp2 ça peut
paraître dérisoire par rapport
c'est un jour je m'en restait un
document que nous avons révélé qui
montre bien le mans sont en deçà des
reee
contrairement à ce qui dit il n'y en
avait pas il y en avait pas et on voit
comment dans tous ces courriers qu'on a
révélé combien ce mensonge se créent du
désordre
c'est à dire qu'il désarme et il accroît
les lourdeurs et lenteurs les pesanteurs
bureaucratiques ou sein même de
l'appareil d'état je continue la
chronologie en effet savait que le jour
où elle démissionne ou elle qui depuis
tous ont visé le 31 janvier c'est le
jour où le comité d'urgence de l'om
est-ce demande aux états de mettre en
place
je cite des mesures fortes pour détecter
la maladie à un stade précoce isolé
traiter les cas retracer les contacts et
promouvoir des mesures de distanciation
sociales proportionnelles aux risques en
clair une bonne politique c'était
mobilisation générale pour des masques
et le virus ayant été séquencé
production général de test et qu'est-ce
qui lé frère déteste rien tout ça rien
de tout ça c'est justement les pays qui
s'en sortent mieux
regardez l'allemagne c'est justement ce
qu'ils ont fait nous publions dans notre
chronologie
la france est la lanterne rouge en
nombre de tests en nombre de tests par
rapport à ce que font d'autres pays
qu'est ce que c'est le test ça permet de
savoir si vous au moins on est un
porteur sain ce virus du coup faire
attention à ce que nous nous retrouvions
pas et à nous isoler et à isoler les uns
des autres et à faire attention à la
propagation elle même je continue le
lendemain c'est le jour le 1er février
où je voulais dit les pays de l'espace
schengen suspendent leur vie
la chine ce que ne fait pas la france je
continue 14 février décès en france
c'est un touriste chinois le premier
décès après ce sont des non pas des
touristes et sont des travailleurs
français ce qui me 14 février des cas
qui arrivent sur le terrain car avant
que le virus mais il meurt à l'hôpital
bichat
je souligne c'est aussi le premier décès
hors d'asie et le premier en europe
ça ne se passe pas en italie ça se passe
d'abord en france 14 février que se
passe-t-il deux jours plus tard vous
vous en rappelez vous le 16 février
après une histoire de vidéo ou très
discutable concernant monsieur benjamin
griveaux qui portait les couleurs dans
marche pour la mairie de paris
et bien la ministe la santé elle-même ce
qui s'ajoute au cas de la conseillère de
l'elysée
tout d'un coup en pleine crise dit je
veux être maire de paris la ministre de
la santé qui après fera savoir dans une
déclaration un peu bizarre parce que
faite au détour d'une sorte de portrait
dans le monde que en janvier elle aurait
dit au premier ministre les municipales
ne pourront pas se tenir
c'est ce qu'elle dit au monde et le 16
elle est faible et le fait pourquoi le
quitte en larmes à ce moment là le
ministériel dit qu'elle c'est ce vers
quoi on va aller dans les semaines
atteint les municipales ne peuvent pas
se tenir
elle sait que c'est très grave et elle
va quand même s'occuper des municipales
je veux pas dire mais c'est comme dans
les fables de la fontaine les rats
quittent le navire
vous savez les animaux malades de la
peste
c'est aussi une fable de la fontaine
tout le monde est alors je continue sa
son successeur le 18 février donc
olivier ferrand qui volleye verront la
france est prête car nous avons un
système de santé extrêmement solide
alors en l'occurrence la suite va
montrer quoi et nous l'avons documenté
sur mediapart que nous avons des
soignants et des soignantes extrêmement
solide
courageux solidaires inventif ayant ce
sursaut les mêmes qui réclamaient des
moyens pour l'hôpital
les mêmes qui avaient traité avec morgue
je rappelle que la formule de monsieur
mâcon au début de son quinquennat
je n'ai pas d'argent magique c'est à une
aide soignante qu'il le dit et nous ne
lui avions rappelé il y a tout juste
deux ans de cela avec jean jacques
bourdin
quand nous l'avions interviewé mediapart
et rmc je lui avais dit je l'avais dit
mais l'argent magique il est là dans les
paradis fiscaux il avait balayé ça je
m'y avait rappelé qu'à l'époque des gens
étaient admis à l'hôpital était sur des
brancards aux urgences faute de lits
dans les hôpitaux
qu'est ce qui va se passer c'est pas
notre système de santé qui va être
solide je rappelle que beaucoup de ceux
qui aujourd'hui sauvent des vies étaient
en grève manifestaient et se faisait
réprimer vous l'avez traité dans vos
vidéos et dans vos reportages sur le
terrain non qu'est ce qui se passe il se
passe que des gens réussissent à être au
rendez vous par la solidarité malgré
quoi le manque de masquer le manque de
test le manque de blues
le manque de lits le manque de moyens et
c'est quand même ça qui s'est passé
devant nous 22 février 22 février le
directeur général de l'om s10 la fenêtre
d'opportunité pour contenir l'épidémie
se rétrécit il dit attention attention
les autres qui ont entendu qu'ils me
pensais masse qui ont pensé tests qui
ont pensé un dispositif sans faire un
des tam tams en faire la grande
déclaration paternaliste du président un
ils n'ont pas fait ça en allemagne ils
n'ont pas un n'a pas fait ça madame
merkel le président allemand
il a dit on n'est pas en guerre non non
il n'ya pas d'ennemis il n'ya pas de
nation qui se battent les unes contre
les autres
hier
haye a mené pour la vie tous ensemble
c'est ça qui me dit et qu'on aurait
plutôt aimé entendre plutôt que des
rodomontades il dit la fenêtre
d'opportunité se rétrécit et le 26
février le directeur général de la santé
dont quatre jours après nous dit les
tests ont été disponibles les masques
nous avons débloqué les stocks
stratégiques
en clair ce n'est pas un sujet dit il
ce n'est pas un sujet d'accord encore
une fois nous l'avons documenté c'est
toujours un sujet et à ce moment là on
en est au concrètement dans les
commandes en l'aidant la disposition des
choses mais à la fin du mois de février
je n'arrive voix ils n'arrivent pas à
faire rentrer nous avons documenté que y
compris beaucoup d'entrepreneurs alors
ils nous ont demandé de pas toujours
donner leur identité parce qu'ils sont
dans le business ont proposé leurs
services
on dit moi je suis en affaires avec la
chine je peux vous apporter tant de
masques je peux faire ceci je peux faire
cela et nous montrons il y en a au moins
4 5 qui ont témoigné dans notre enquête
comment ils se sont faits blackboulé
comme on ne les a pas écoutés
comment la bureaucratie a cru qu'elle
s'en sorte et encore une fois le
désordre vient du fait de ne pas avoir
dit la vérité
dante en place je souligne quand même il
faut revenir sur la psychologie
parce qu'il faut essayer de comprendre
tout ça sont pas des gens qui veulent
que l'on soit malade
pourquoi ont-ils été aveugle
irresponsable à ce point dans cette même
semaine de février
il ya le premier conseil des ministres
officiellement consacré au qu'ovide 19
un samedi le 29 février
quelles décisions en retient ton le 49-3
le 49-3 sur la réforme des retraites
obsession économique obsession de faire
passer leur agenda idéologique la
réforme des retraites dont tout
récemment le président du groupe
parlementaire en marche gilles legendre
viens de dire il faudra la laisser
tomber
ah bon alors c'est est décisif et
aujourd'hui ça l'est plus bon ça prouve
que il était il allait dans le mur et
obsessions idéologiques et obsessions
politicienne parce que l'obsession
politicienne la première déclaration du
président qui nous dit je ferme les
écoles mais je vous dis allez voter
aller voter plus de 20 millions de
personnes vont se retrouver entre 20 et
30 millions à aller dans des lieux où il
ya beaucoup de gens savaient que
beaucoup de d'assesseurs et d'élus vont
y compris la poursuite de la campagne
municipale
quand on prend symboliquement la mort de
patrick devedjian qui a fait beaucoup de
meetings électoraux la poursuite de la
campagne électorale a mis en péril des
gens c'est totalement contradictoire de
dire je ferme les écoles mais je vous
dit d'aller voter comme et
contradictoire je vous confie mais
attention aller travailler car nous
avons révélé aussi que la ministre du
travail madame pénicaud dans une des
échanges que nous avons révélé a dit va
falloir elle a dit challenge aimé ça
voulait dire presque un mode de chantage
sur les entreprises du btp qui
arrêtaient les chantiers sur le thème
vous aurez pas les aides si vous arrêtez
les chantiers nous l'avons révélé ça
aussi l'obsession idéologique
le 2 mars le ms demande des mesures
précoces et agressive
s'il ya des mesures précoces et
agressive les pays peuvent arrêter la
transmission
demain le 2 mars 4 mars pour parole du
gouvernement sur france inter on ne
fermera pas toutes les écoles en france
si nous basculons dans le stade 3 à
savoir une épidémie qui circulent dans
tout le territoire
on ne va pas arrêter la vie en france on
ne va pas arrêter la vie en france et le
6 mars pédagogie présidentielle emmanuel
macron et son épouse vont à paris au
théâtre
la vie continue il n'y a aucune raison
mise à part pour les populations
fragilisées
de modifier nos habitudes de sortie la
pièce pour l'ironie de cette histoire
s'intitule par le bout du nez et elle
met en scène un psychiatre et un
président de la république
victime de démangeaisons du nez juste
avant son discours d'investiture alors
je ne sais pas si c'est une allusion à
pinocchio 1 le nez qui s'allonge mais on
est dans une histoire qui est quand même
s'ils démentent
c'est vraiment tu ne nous ne disons pas
ça pour pour eux c'est vrai quand on
arrive au niveau du mois de mars début
mars
c'est le moment où en italie on voit que
la crise est en train d'avancer ces
quelques jours avant qu'il prenne la
décision du confinement et en france on
commence à compter les kroumirs d'un des
deux cas qu'est ce que je veux vous dire
et puis c'est que c'est une épreuve qui
nous concerne tous qui n'a pas
d'étiquette partisane
qu'on soit de droite de gauche du centre
on est logé à tous la même enseigne
et c'est un moment où en effet il faut
être solidaire faut faire front ensemble
mais pour faire front ensemble c'est
comme dans un combat faut avoir
confiance dans les chefs ou ceux qui
sont en tête et qui donne des consignes
et les consignes elles sont crédibles si
elles sont vraies elles sont il ya de la
confiance il y a de la vérité vous par
exemple qu'elle est clair vous avez vu à
certains moments entre telles
déclarations mais c'est tout ce que je
viens de vous dire sur certains fois par
exemple mais ne met tout ce que je viens
de vous dire et si des mois encore une
fois la déclaration d'hier décider quand
même je vais vous dire autre chose
nous avons montré par exemple il ya une
haute autorité de la santé publique en
france il ya des structures qui existent
le président afin de faire sa première
déclaration créé un conseil scientifique
comité scientifique ont ce comité
scientifique tour du professeur
delfraissy des gens respectables on ne
sait pas comment il est créé c'est pas
voilà c'est le fait du prince
pourrait-on dire
et les reliant entre le prince et
différentes personnes nous comité
scientifique pour arroser pour ceux qui
nous regardent donc c'est avec monsieur
delfraissy intérêt on peut retrouver des
personnes de l'institut pasteur on
retrouve aussi didier rahout qui a même
cédé
sociologue un épidémiologiste qui au
début avait sous-estimé avait dit que ce
serait un peu comme la grippe donc des
gens qui aussi ceux des chefs de
services de manutention suis trompé mais
qu'est ce que je vous dis on est au
coeur de ce ce présidentialisme nous des
armes dans des moments comme ça
le président est un chef de l'état dans
l'état il ya des administrations il ya
un haut conseil à la santé publique gelé
rappeler il y avait un plan stratégique
pour les pandémies d'anciens
responsables du ministère de la défense
ont rappelé qu'au ministère de la
défense
on connaît comme pour des guerres
sanitaires on connaît un plan
stratégique qu'on peut déclencher pour
les pandémies et il s'est étonné il
s'appelle louis gautier ancien
responsable du ministère de la défense
que ça ça n'est pas été déclenché dès
janvier il ya des structures
il ya des procédures il ya des
professionnels le président s'entoure de
son comité ad-hoc
on ne sait pas comment il est nommé quel
que soit le caractère responsable de ces
gens on ne sait pas comment y débattent
on ne sait pas comment ils décident
leurs avis sont en ligne mais ce sont
pas des avis grand public
on ne sait pas quelle est la procédure
qui a permis de produire leur avis on ne
sait pas d'ailleurs c'est très
énigmatique tout d'un coup le président
annonce des décisions tout seul hier
sans que nous sachions quelle est la
procédure de ses décisions et le comité
scientifique on ne l'a pas entendu jeudi
au même moment
si vous écoutez les déclarations le
lendemain du ministre de l'éducation ou
d'une ministre de l'intérieur qui qui
tout d'un coup devient un professionnel
de la santé
vous voyez bien que ils sont pas dans
les clous ils savent pas trop comment
ils vont faire
ils savent pas ce que veut dire cette
programmation sur les masques et je
voudrais dire quand vous dites des
décalages sur les déclarations il ya
hier
de la même manière qu'à un moment la
porte parole de l'elysée avait dit les
masques ça ne sert à rien ce qui est je
ne sais pas comment mais un masque un
truc qu'il ya beaucoup de déclarations
contradictoires entre des moments
ou c'est en sortant dans d'autres un peu
lancé c'est en clair c'était stupide de
dire ça c'était stupide c'était une
stupidité bon mais hier le président
balaye en disant ça n'aurait aucun sens
de tester tout le monde
le test est il des il faudra tester que
les gens qui ont des symptômes
c'est un nouveau mensonge pour masquer
la pénurie de tests tous les
épidémiologistes vous dise
il faut avoir une politique de test
général lorsqu'on sait que des
évolutions vont dire que on peut aussi
dire les gars qui sont par ailleurs
c'est un type bien ce serait bien bien
sûr vous et moi est en très bonne santé
la d'apparence et nouvel hébergeur pour
des gens qui eux sont en fragilité donc
la question des masques et la question
des tests sont des questions décisives
quand le président nous dit hier il ya
eu des erreurs je dois nous devons nous
réinventer et moi le premier mais se
réinventer s'est arrêtée de bluffer et
c'est surtout si je peux me permettre
arrêtez de penser qu'on est des enfants
arrêtez de nous infantiliser
ce n'est plus possible je ne sais pas
dans quel monde vit emmanuel macron
peut-être celui de bonaparte et napoléon
mais ce n'est plus possible de se dire
que dans ce monde où nous avons des
défis si compliqué une seule personne
arrive avec tout une communication qui
précède sur le président thaumaturge sur
la présidente paternotte et que tout
d'un coup on va avoir la lumière une
présidence démocratique qu'est ce
qu'elle aurait dû faire
elle aurait dû se présenter avec
d'autres avec eux quels sont les avis
des scientifiques
avec quels sont les gens qui sont en
charge montrer que c'est une bataille
d'equipe que c'est pas il n'y a pas
quelqu'un qui tous seuls va réfléchir et
décider c'est à dire conseil
scientifique sur lequel mais c'est bien
ce que je dis mais ce conseil
scientifique
il mord sur les sur les plates bandes du
haut conseil de santé publique
et je rappelle de la haute autorité de
santé plus mais je rappelle en plus qu'
il ya une leçon dépens
amy est d'ailleurs dans le club de
mediapart il ya eu une lettre
interpellant les scientifiques qui sont
à la tête puisqu'il ya eu un deuxième
conseil vous savez le caire avec
françoise barré sinoussi qui a eu le
prix nobel pour ses découvertes sur le
virus du vih sur le sida et le
professeur delfraissy est aussi
quelqu'un qui a été un spécialiste de
cette pandémie
qu'est ce que nous a appris dans nos
sociétés
la bataille sur le virus du vih et sur
cette pandémie par rapport à l'hécatombe
qu'elle a provoquée que nous devons nous
devons justement ne pas être des enfants
que nous ne devons pas nous laisser
instrumentaliser par des gens qui
décident à notre place
les combattants du sida symbolisée par
l'organisation act up magnifié par le
film 120 battements par minute qui à
l'époque ont été réprimées qui à
l'époque ont été calomniés qui à
l'époque ont été méprisés
avec derrière le préjugés homophobes
avec l'idée ça ne me concerne pas ça
concerne des populations à risque
le préjugé y compris on en a parlé
contre les travailleurs du sexe et des
travailleuses du sexe et tout cela est
bien qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
dit on prend notre destin parce qu'ils
ont vu qu'ils étaient face à des
politiques irresponsables à une forme
d'irresponsabilité politique par rapport
à la pandémie et aussi par rapport à une
ignorance savante l'idée que le savoir
serait univoque et que en matière de
santé il y aurait qu'une seule certitude
vous le voyez dans le débat sur ce virus
que nous
des polémiques il ya des débats il ya
des ja des pessimistes
il ya des plus optimistes il ya des
recherches en cours donc dans ce cas là
nous les premiers concernés
la population doit être acteur et c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est je souligne ça
ils ont dit silence également or ils ont
dit aussi bien en anglais qu'en français
le savoir est une arme knowledge in the
weapon nous avons le droit de savoir
nous ne ferons pas silence alors je dis
cela parce que ont rejoint le travail de
la presse dans un moment comme service
gestion sur cette question du droit de
savoir de la présente parle beaucoup de
cette question d'aider des masques
notamment
vous évoquez notamment dans votre
enquête qui a des entreprises françaises
qui vont pas être prises en compte et
qui aurait peut-être pu accélérer c'est
ça c'est ce qu'on a raconté on a raconté
puis je vous le disais tout à l'heure
plusieurs témoignages d'entreprises
entrepreneurs qui ont proposé leurs
services et notre dernière enquête
semble dire que l'état français a décidé
de faire un choix monopolistique avec
quatre grands groupes
quatre grands groupes n'ont pas tous
français et notamment chinois qui aurait
le monopole de cette livraison de
magique
est ce que nous disent ces entrepreneurs
c'est exactement ce qu'il fallait passer
et vous évoquez notamment parce que moi
j'ai texte d une entreprise française
qui est la seule entreprise française de
la liste des carnations qui a notamment
une entreprise qui est basé de
production à yohan hautcoeur de la
pandémie était fermé à ce moment là au
coeur de la pandémie et les autres
entreprises sont sondés conglomérat
chinois et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'on se fait prendre en otage
en otage des tarifs en otage des pris en
otage des livraisons les fameux avion
cargo n'arrive pas au rythme qui était
prévu et au lieu de faire et c'est ce
que disait un peu au lieu
si si on prend l'image que je n'aime pas
guerrière de monsieur mâcon c'est pas
une histoire de bataille on savait une
armée régulière avec tous ces bataillons
quand on voit tous ces soignants qui on
improvise
c'est qu'ils ont inventé et tous et une
guérilla une bataille comme ça donc ça
veut dire qu'on utilise toutes les
entreprises toutes les poussettes et les
gants mais non c'est toujours le
verticalisme du présidentialisme est une
faiblesse il nous désarme et il donne
toujours des décisions autoritaires
univoque limité et on est au coeur
encore une fois de ce que nous apprend
cette épreuve avant d'évoquer ce qu'elle
nous apprend on empruntait dans l'est
dans les conclusions à la fin de ce live
mais sur la question des masques on sait
notamment il ya plusieurs extraits de
réponse ils sont prises par rapport aux
lèvres qu'on a pu faire et qu olivier
viron sur brut où on avait évoqué avec
lui sur ce direct le fait qu'ils
auraient 2 milliard de masques vous vous
évoquez dans votre article que c'est
seulement 17 que c'est depuis le 21 mars
l'état consomme 40 millions de masques
par semaine et qu'on en a seulement 17,5
c'est à peu près ça donc dans l'es9
hiatus ça veut dire que ça c'est notre
chef de vendredi leur faudrait deux ans
pour acheminer les 2 milliard de masques
si on reste à ce rythme là donc en gros
dans ce que vous expliquez dans votre
enquête c par rapport aux déclarations
qu'a pu faire les gérants en facebook
live ici même sur sur brut de padt
milliard de masques et loïc de livraison
on en est très très lourde et à notre
enquête et a été en deux temps
premièrement le mention sur les masques
et en deuxième temps 15 jours après
comme une semaine plus tôt après comment
à cause de ce mensonge il court derrière
la france s'est mis sur le marché est
trop tard et il court derrière dans des
incohérences de décisions savait mais
pour montrer comment ces incohérences
vous avez même eu un ancien directeur
directeur général de la santé qui a
raconté william dab
comment il est à la retraite comment il
a proposé d'aller dans la réserve
sanitaire de se mettre au service comme
médecin et la bureaucratie lui a dit on
a pas votre diplôme de médecin et donc
ils attendaient toujours ce que ce que
je veux dire c'est c'est pour ça que je
vous disais ça il faut essayer de
comprendre d'où vient ce désordre qui
est quand même très inquiétant c'est à
dire comme un état qui est faible comme
un état qui est qu'ils aient épuisé
et comme un état qui est impuissant ce
ne sont pas les personnes qui en sont
responsables il ya plein de gens de
bonne volonté derrière tout cela
c'est une culture étatique qui est
épuisée parce que depuis des décennies
elles continuent à fonctionner dans ce
régime de monarchie absolue où pour
reprendre une image peut-être d'un
proverbe chinois le poisson pourrit par
la tête
on attend tous d'un seul essai et du
coup se verticalisme se diffuse à
l'ensemble du fonctionnement et du coup
ça des armes
ça crée du désordre et c'est exactement
l'explication de ce qu'elles soient
concrètement on en est où aujourd'hui je
veux dire là maintenant et ça on va
continuer ça je ne peux pas vous dire à
la date d'aujourd'hui à la date d'entrée
mais en tout cas sur le moment où s'est
arrêté à votre enquête au niveau des
publications la france court la france
court derrière ces masques et ces tests
d'où le caractère flou imprécis et
contradictoire des déclarations du
président derrière didier on appelle vos
ils ont temps et en heure aujourd'hui on
rattrape on dit qu'il faudrait mais mais
prenez même des décisions qui sont
demandés y compris par les élus ont dit
les masques ont dit les tests mais aussi
du coup il faudrait que les gens
puissent se retrouver
vous savez les octets les hôtels sont
vides on devrait pouvoir utiliser ces
hôtels pour faire que des personnes qui
ont le virus mais qui ne sont pas en mal
d'être d'être en danger
un qui ne sont pas en danger qui ont de
la fièvre mais qui ne sont pas en danger
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de respirateur
qui ont pas [ __ ] mais qu'il faudrait
isoler pour qu'elle ne retourne pas chez
elle pour qu'elle ne contamine pas la
famille des amis etc
on devrait réquisitionner des hôtels on
devait réquisitionner des entreprises
ont drevet réquisitionner des stocks de
masques qui sont dans certaines
industries
on devrait nous dire de manière
transparente quels sont tous les
laboratoires qui actuellement font des
tests et les fabriquent
on devrait nous dire comment on peut
être testé on devrait nous dire tout
cela mais tout ça ne peut pas venir dans
oracle présidentielle tout ça devrait
venir encore une fois d'une culture où
on dit la vérité et concrètement c'est à
dire que quand on parle toutes vos
enquêtes la conclusion serait de dire
quoique on gère une crise sur une
pénurie pas sur des faits scientifiques
que c'est comme toutes les crises
les crises sont des révélateurs il ya
plein de cause vous savez qu'il ya plein
de débats intellectuels sur ce que cette
pandémie nous dit de notre monde de
notre monde de consommation de notre
monde de vitesse de notre monde de
globalisation de notre monde du tout
marchand et du tout économique
ça ce sont des débats importants mais on
voit bien qu'il ya des différences dans
les certains états dans la façon d'avoir
su faire face au virus
il n'y a pas eu de confinement
généralisée en corée du sud à taiwan ou
japon ni en allemagne
donc on serait aussi on pourrait parler
bien de gros cahier de payer des
stratégies différentes voilà même si la
majorité ce que je veux dire c'est que
il faut qu'on comprenne pourquoi
pourquoi nous français on se retrouve
dans le mode de lutte contre cette
pandémie qui est entre nous le plus
archaïque le plus moyenâgeux restez chez
vous restez chez vous voilà ce qu'on
vous restez chez vous et on ne dit cette
phrase en même temps de manière
hypocrite parce que il y a il faut en
même temps il ya des gens qui
travaillent
il ya des gens qui s'expose mais on nous
dit restez chez vous pourquoi c'est la
seule chose qu'on nous dit pourquoi est
ce que c'est la seule perspective qu'on
nous donne
parce que le reste n'a pas été fait
c'est à dire qu'on fait porter sur nos
comportements et avec des conséquences
les soignants nous disent deux mois de
confinement
il y aura des conséquences il y aura des
conséquences psychologiques y aura des
conséquences en termes de santé
pas seulement pour le coronavirus pour
des personnes âgées ou le voir
des bus ont début là on a soulevé sa et
depuis le chiffre et on a demandé la
publicité sur les morts dans les ehpad
et c'était important de dire je fais une
petite parenthèse parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de médecins et certains mêmes
que l'on parlait des andes et facebook
live sur brut de dire qu' ils ont vu
même des patients qui étaient là
d'habitude pour d'autres pathologies
il n'y avait disparu de plus et même
temps ils sont toujours là enfin bien
sûr elle déchire toujours bien cher et
donc c'est vrai que c'est important peut
on était donné ce conseil pour ceux qui
nous regardent pas ce que c'est ce que
certains médecins ont pu dire il faut
toujours consulter il faut toujours
aller prendre le prendre les devants et
ont cédé des traitements qui sont
importants et sur et avec les inégalités
sociales vous savez qu'aujourd'hui le
premier département concerné c'est la
seine saint denis donc il est concerné
pourquoi parce que c'est là où les
inégalités sociales pèsent les
difficultés sociales pèsent et donc vous
voyez bien qu'il faut qu'on comprenne
pourquoi
pourquoi au fond on nous on ne nous
propose qu'une réponse qui porte sur
nous mêmes et sur notre responsabilité
alors ok nous sommes nous sommes nous
sommes observant nous nous protégeons et
nous protégeons les autres bien sûr nous
ne faisons pas parce que le président
nous le demande nous faisons parce que
nous savons qu'il faut faire ça qu'il
faut faire les gestes barrières et c'est
ici même à mediapart nous avons pris les
décisions du confinement et du
télétravail avant que emmanuel macron
l'annoncent mais mais mais du coup dû qu
il faut que nous comprenions ce qui
s'est passé il faut que nous comprenions
pourquoi on nous impose cela avec tous
les dégâts que cela suppose et on va pas
ajouter en prime le fait de ne plus être
des citoyens de ne plus avoir le droit
de comprendre de questionner
d'interpeller rendez vous contre le
président et il a été interpellé sur le
club de mediapart par des abonnés pas de
conférence de presse
pas de réponse à des questions parce que
vous justement vous sollicitent cette
fin dans le fait tous nos enquêtes
j'aime venir dans vos articles fait pour
toi tu es noir
la dernière enquête la boit
noir ce qu'on a pour toi elle fait une
longueur presque en papier comme ça et
ce que vous faites donc un prion les
invités le travail de journaliste
d'investigation aussi sévère que vous
faites votre enquête il ya des sources d
qui vous envoie d après vous vérifiez
vous comptez utiliser tout ça mais on
parlait vous allez le bextra des noirs
le sida auprès des ministres à
l'histoire le contradictoire
c'est une règle essentielle le
contradictoire et nous disons nous
envoyons des questions nous donnons des
délais nous sommes nous retardons
parfois la publication et en france et
bien quand c'est des réserves justement
ça comme par hasard comme par hasard
qu'ils ne nous répond pas l'état depuis
l'elysée le ministère ne nous répondent
pas mr la santé vous a répondu sur
quelques éléments se régale que éléments
l'écart exemple risque ont peut-être il
y là il a fait des réponses que nous on
a intégré d'ailleurs à chaque fois on
met ça dans l'onglet prolonger mais qui
ne démentait pas le caractère factuelle
de nos révélations d'ailleurs le
président de la république les a reconnu
hier en disant oui il ya eu des retards
que vous n'avez pas eu de réponse par
exemple des questions qui sont restées
sans réponses auprès du ministère de la
santé et d'autres parce que j'avais par
exemple sur c'est sur ces personnes qui
ont proposé d'acheter des masques
il ya des personnes pour contextualiser
c'est des entreprises qui ont sous la
hutte il ya eu il ya eu une phrase un
peu méprisante disant que c'était des
personnes qui se pousser du col alors
qu'en fait c'est notamment ce sont des
entreprises qui avaient toutes les
habilitations auprès du ministère pour
faire pour faire ce travail
mais comment dire on a besoin on a
besoin là je voudrais souligner aussi il
n'y a pas que la presse dans un moment
comme ça il ya le parlement il ya le
parlement et le fait qu'on soit aussi
dans ce système de la parole
présidentielle d'en haut
si on appelle à l'union face à une crise
comme ça et bien c'est pas simplement je
rencontre les chefs de groupes
parlementaires et les partis
d'opposition pour leur dire ce que j'ai
décidé ça veut dire que le parlement
doit être actif
cela a été rappelé par les historiens si
on mediapart vous savez que pendant la
guerre
18 et c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que
clemenceau va finalement surgir le
parlement avait le droit d'intervenir le
parlement auditionnait les généraux le
parlement les bousculer le parlement
mettez en cause leur décision
c'est à dire que le parlement il n'avait
pas été mis en congés il n'avait pas été
mis sous cloche
et aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'on devrait
avoir on devrait avoir déjà un travail
d' enquête du parlement on devrait déjà
avoir un rebondissement à partie par les
yeux de mission dans une dizaine de
jours bien sûr qui m'annonce de richard
ferrand qui essayent déjà et on essaye
mais mes classes et pas de vision
tarnais vous voyez bien les infos et
viennent pas par le parlement
actuellement elles viennent par non
elles viennent par notre travail
un jeu rappelle si vous écrivez qu'ovide
19h mediapart.fr cesser notre adresse
pour nous envoyer des informations des
documents etc
et depuis c'est comme ça que nous avons
travaillé un coville 19h mediapart.fr
donc nous nous nous faisons ce travail
d' alerte en lien avec la société grâce
à la société grâce à sa vigilance
qu'est-ce que vous conclut un peu de
tout c'est toutes ces enquêtes peut-être
parce que c'est vrai que c'était
important de se dire ça le recul que
vous peut être en avoir aujourd'hui même
si le recul il faudra le prohon
peut-être dans quelques semaines donc
quelques mois et peut-être d'ici là
aussi via d'autres révélations vous
pourrez faire prochainement
on n'a pas eu de l'impréparation
notamment mais moi c'est ce que je lis
sur toute cette chronologie où vous
expliquer le temps très long de la mise
en place pour commander des masques pour
utiliser toutes les tous les moyens
possibles pour avoir une un retour
rapide de masques chirurgicaux et ffp2 2
/ blues vous voyez bien que cette
épidémie est une énigme
ainsi elle pose plein de questions
une
encore médical une énigme scientifique
une énigme sur notre monde globalisé
vous savez on est devant un truc quand
même qui est sidérant
on est dans ce monde que nous on nous
disait multilatérale il ya les nations
unies où il ya l'organisation mondiale
de la santé où il ya l'union européenne
et là c'est comme si en fait vous savez
c'est comme dans une maison il ya un
court circuit est le disjoncteur fait
sauter toute l'électricité et là il ya
un virus là l'élément de vie le plus
ancestrales encore une fois un virus les
virus ont précédé la parution de
l'espèce humaine et ils continueront
d'exister le jour où notre espèce
disparaîtra et bien bon ça fait
disjoncter ce monde
ce monde plus la moitié de l'humanité
est immobilisé et confiné et c'est bon
donc ça c'est pas de la responsabilité
du pouvoir français
c'est une interpellation globale et ça
pose tous ces débats qui ont lieu déjà
sur le monde d'après et on pourrait dire
que pour le monde d'après c'est le monde
d'aujourd'hui et seule seconde d'après
justement j'ai envie de solliciter le
journaliste mais aussi fait vous avez
nommé parle très librement veut depuis
le début de ce direct qu'est ce que vous
attendez de ce monde c'est un cetain
c'est un monde sur un autre modèle que
celui que nous avons aujourd'hui il ya
eu un très fort article de romaric godin
sur cette économisme qui a imprégné nos
sociétés
cette bulle économique bulle du profit
brut de la croissance bulle de la
production qu'est-ce qu'on redécouvre à
l'occasion d'un moment comme ça les
solidarités les plus élémentaires
l'entr'aide un c est cette idée que
l'important c'est d'abord de vivre
correctement dignement son gazon c'est
donc justement mais d'abord sur
nous-mêmes dans ce qui s'invente vous
savez quand vous voyez ce qui se fait
dans les solidarités
mais en fait c'est le monde excusez moi
mais c'est le monde que toutes les
luttes récentes appellent de leur voeu
que les gilets jaunes appelaient de
leurs voeux que les soignants appelé de
l'eau
veut que les gens qui ont fait cet appel
avec oxfam avec attac que les jeunes
mouvement sur l'écologie appellent de
leurs voeux
ces idées là ils sont dans la société
elles sont pas au pouvoir
c'est ça le problème et l'autre l'autre
élément quand même qui doit nous
interpeller
regardez l'europe et c'est terrible on
sait que les virus n'ont pas de
frontières on sait qu'ils attaquent eu
toutes les humanités et donc les
humanités sont solidaires l'union
européenne on nous a dit ça doit être le
lieu de la solidarité l'union européenne
elle arrive à se réunir pendant des
heures quand il s'agit de mettre à
genoux l'économie de la grèce parce
qu'elle veut faire des choix économiques
qui me déplaisent elle se réunit encore
la semaine dernière deux jours pour
faire un plan daide à l'économie
insuffisant bien moins que ce qu'elle a
fait pour les banques en 2008 et elle
n'a pas été capable de faire une réunion
de crise sur cette pandémie
même si les questions sanitaires ne sont
pas dans son portefeuille
mais en l'occurrence l'austérité qu'elle
a imposées et qui a frappé les hôpitaux
en europe et vient de son ressort
donc l'europe elle aurait dû se bouger
elle aurait dû soit assez bougé il nous
faut une autre europe
il nous faut une autre europe qui
fonctionne autrement comme déjà la crise
grecque nous le montrait ya cinq ans
juste au moment du déclenchement du
confinement
on a révélé les audio de yannis
varoufakis vous savez ce ministre des
finances grec qui avait enregistré les
réunions de l'eurogroupe
cette boîte noire où sont prises des
décisions sur nos économies c'était
encore le cas la semaine dernière
mais vous savez qu'il ya pas de compte
rendu vous savez que ça dure parfois des
heures il n'y a pas de compte-rendu ya
jamais de comptes rendus
c'est à dire ce n'est pas transparent
donc quel monde nous faut-il eh bien je
vais vous dire tout simplement
il nous faut un monde démocratique
toujours plus de démocratie vous savez
dans ton pendant la révolution française
à un moment où elle est assaillie il dit
de l'audace
ou encore de l'audace toujours de
l'audace
et bien aujourd'hui nous devons dire de
la démocratie encore de la démocratie
toujours de la démocratie ça veut dire
pas de pouvoir absolu
pas de présidence qui décident à notre
place cela veut dire des contre pouvoirs
cela veut dire une démocratie vivante
avec une presse indépendante et libre
cela veut dire tout ce qui fait vous
savez on parle de la nature aujourd'hui
car le virus c'est la nature et on se
dit quand même c'est une réflexion aussi
sur la façon dont nous on se croit très
puissant très puissant
vous savez que les virus naissent aussi
c'est nouveau virus apparaissent de la
transgression des barrières avec
certaines espèces animales dans ce
contexte d'extension des villes les
marchés d'animaux vivants donc en chine
et ainsi de suite d'animaux sauvages
alors pourquoi je vous dis ça qu'est ce
que nous apprend la nature si un de mes
organes essentiels ma tête mon coeur
tombe on me coupe la tête et mon coeur
explose
je meurs une plante voulu couper une
branche voulu couper une racine
elle ne meurt pas elle repousse qu'est
ce que nous apprend la nature qu'est ce
que nous apprend du plant n'y a pas de
centre le tout est dans la partie et la
partie et dont le taux est inversement
elles nous apprennent linverse de la
verticalité l'homme a trop conçu et ça
lui a réussi parce que dieu sait si il a
été une puissance une puissance qui
s'est imposé à la nature mais il a vu le
monde à sa façon le cerveau tout en haut
et la verticalité que nous apprend la
nature l'horizontalité le dialogue
le tremblement là le sentiment de la
phrase
lité le sentiment de l'entr'aide savez
les plantes on appelle ça même la
timidité des plantes vous savez que
c'est montrer ça dans les forêts
tropicales on voit un arbre poussé et on
voit que ces branches se débrouille pour
laisser un espace entre les branches
d'un autre à un autre arbre c'est à dire
que les plantes
nous devons apprendre d'elle dans une
écologie du politique
il ya beaucoup je termine juste ce que
je voulais vous dire la leçon de cette
épidémie c'est qu'il nous faut sortir
des logiques de puissance de domination
de pouvoir de verticalité domini science
d'une science qui parfois peut se
tromper d'omni puissance de pouvoir
politique qui parfois peuvent s'égarer
une ou deux questions de saint-hernin de
conclure ce live justement il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui réagissent par
rapport à l'union européenne c'est vrai
qu'on a pu voir par exemple en italie en
espagne certains commentaires de
personnes de dire on est abandonné par
l'union européenne d'un autre côté on a
vu en france parfois des patients pris
en charge par d'autres pays européens
et puis on a aussi par exemple va bruno
le maire milot économique et la semaine
dernière disait excellente accord entre
milices entre ministres des finances
européens sur la réponse économique duo
coronavirus 500 milliards d'euros
disponibles immédiatement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un peu comme
analyse de tous alain côté on peut avoir
d'un point et politique veut dire bon
ben on voit qu'il ya voilà par exemple
500 milliards on peut dire que c'est
peut-être très bien je sais pas qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous et puis d'un
autre peut-être la montée du
nationalisme dans certains pays sur la
réunion de l'eurogroupe justement la
semaine dernière les chiffres annoncés
sont dérisoires encore une fois j'oublie
j'ai oublié les chiffres je sais plus et
c'est combien de milliards mais les
aides aux banques
les aides aux banques au moment de la
crise de 2008 était bien supérieure et
des aides aux banques pour que tout
reparte comme avant pour que tout
reparte comme avant
donc c'est évidemment insuffisant alors
évidemment vous avez raison
qu'est ce qui est le risque de cette
pandémie s'est pas acquis et à un monde
d'après nouveau c'est qu'il ya un monde
bien pire et que tout reparte comme
avant de l'autoritarisme
car vous savez certains pouvoirs
politiques y prennent goût à nous
confiner regardez comment monsieur or
ban a fait passer des textes d'exception
et
lee l'état d'exception sanitaires
actuelles rejoint l'état d'exception
policiers que l'on a vu dans notre pays
ces dernières années le symbole de ce
préfet de police qui dit si vous allez
mourir du coronavirus c'est parce que
vous êtes un citoyen passage c'est
exactement ce qui se trouve en
réanimation aujourd'hui sont ceux qui ne
l'ont pas respectée mais c'est indigne
messadi vient ça ça dit bien nous nous
avons le pouvoir face à un peuple qui
est un peuple infantiliser qui est un
peuple que nous surveillons qui est un
peuple que nous que dont nous méfions ya
le risque de l'autoritarisme ya le
risque du productivisme tous repartir
comme avant
la production a baissé le pib a baissé
donc faut retrousser vos manches donc du
coup ne revendiquait pas ne fait pas
grève est encore plus de travail et vous
avez vu que le patron du medef a parlé
de remettre en cause les congés les rtt
ainsi de suite
alors qu'au contraire tout le monde
souffle et ce qui sauve c'est d'abord
les plus démunis et troisièmement
troisièmement il ya le risque du
nationalisme il ya le risque du chacun
pour soi
il ya le risque d'oublier non seulement
l'interdépendance des humanités mais le
fait que dans un moment actuel où nous
pensons à notre prochain eh bien nous
devons comprendre que le prochain c'est
aussi lointain savez l'infirmière qui
restait auprès de boris johnson et qui
l'a sauvée dans l'hôpital elles venaient
de dindes et il l'a dit dans sa
déclaration et l'autre infirmière de
nouvelle zélande
vous savez qu'il y a des médecins qui
ont proposé leurs services
ici en france qui ont une situation
d'irrégularité parce que ce sont des
migrants café le portugal et que demande
un certain nombre de parlementaires je
crois qu'ils sont presque 150 de tout
groupe y compris dans marche cd
régularisation des sans papiers le
portugal portugal le portugal l'a fait
on sait qu'il ya une autre lune signer
le var un peu plus vous savez une ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe dans les
centres
de rétention dans les centres de
rétention du thym digne des personnes
qui sont en rétention
parce que et on considère qu'elles sont
en séjour irrégulier
on les confine là dans des clusters mais
on peut tout à fait c'est pareil la
situation des prisons la situation des
prisons qui est trop oubliée et donc
dans ces moments-là l'humanité
l'humanité dans un moment comme ça
l'humanisme c'est de penser aux plus
fragiles est le plus fragile il est
toujours il ya toujours plus fragile que
nous c'est cette solidarité qui doit
prévaloir
et si en revanche ça fait renaître les
égoïsmes et notamment les égoïsmes
nationaux et bien les égoïsmes nationaux
irons avec l'autoritarisme et ils iront
avec évidemment des logiques au service
d'intérêts sociaux minoritaires
d'intérêt économique du productivisme
comme une ville et la question sociale
qui se posent énormément on l'a vu bon
juste avant ça peut paraître une
éternité dans la période qu'on vit à
angers le mans où tout est à l'arrêt au
ralenti il ya quelques mois il y avait
la grève contre la réforme des retraites
on a eu le mouvement des gilet jaune en
novembre 2018 comment vous voyez là près
d'un point de vue social certains
certaines personnes créent ou espère sa
dépouille se positionne que ça bouge
après qui est peut-être des soulèvements
ici et là nous nous avons une règle à
mediapart nous présidons prédit ne
prédisons pas l'avenir
un journaliste ne doit pas prédire
l'avenir parce qu'il ya là de
l'inattendu de l'improbable vous savez
qui aurait prédit il ya deux ans quand
on faisait cet entretien avec emmanuel
macron avec jean jacques bourdin et où
notre première question je lui dis votre
mouvement vous auriez pas pu l'appeler
en marche mais mais en force car vous
passer en force et on a vu comment la
suite là là totalement trouvé à l'époque
on ne pouvait pas penser que les gilets
jaunes allait surgir mêlée gilet jaune
ils sont sûrs j27 en force
il y avait eu un espoir et finalement
séduit en force de la société s'est pris
en charge et des gens se sont mis au
carrefour pour se prendre en charge et
inventer de nouvelles solidarités
qui aurait prédit
que ce monde dont nous disions qu'il
allait dans le mur par trop d'inégalités
trop d'injustices trop de spéculation
trop de richesses détournées allait être
mis à l'arrêt lens 0 0 1
quelque part par un virus par une
pandémie et pas par une crise financière
et pas par une crise d'une autre nature
on ne l'aurait pas prédit donc il faut
être disponible à l'événement je ne sais
pas de quoi sera fait demain je sais
juste une chose c'est que si nous
voulons éviter qu'il soit fait du pire
qu'il soit fait d'encore plus grave
d'encore plus de malheurs d'inégalité
d'injustice
eh bien il faut nous en occuper nous
mêmes il ne faut pas déléguer il ne faut
pas déléguer et encore moins déléguer à
un seul dans cette vision archaïque
monarchique scénariste un impérial du
pouvoir et bien non il faut se prendre
en charge collectivement il faut
inventer collectivement
cet avenir de ce point de vue nous
journaliste à mediapart nous sommes au
service de jallet dire cecos commune de
d'une humanité où nous sommes tous égaux
en droits pour conclure cela est
peut-être un point important abordé ses
souhaits du tracking évoqués on parle
notamment de cette idée d'une
application dans des termes qui restent
encore à préciser qui devrait notamment
être débattue au parlement d'une
application qui permettrait de savoir
s'ils ont été en contact avec telle ou
telle personne qui aura été porteur du
virus
on sait que ça pose aussi des questions
sur les libertés individuelles etc
et je sais que c'est des sujets sur
lesquels nous nous lavons documenté et
nous sommes évidemment très réservé
savez il ya mise le sens de la nuance et
qu'est-ce que vous documenter exactement
document dessus alors là vraiment il
n'ya pas de scoop en documente vraiment
est d'ailleurs dans cette aile moment là
il ya beaucoup d'investigations source
ouverte la chronologie que je vous ai
fait elle était en source ouverte
la disparition de la conseillère à
l'elysée
il se trouve que c'est mediapart qui a
mis ça en scène mais et c'est là où on
voit qu'on a une presse qui parfois et
des médias qui sont trop dans la
communication et qui ne font pas assez
ce travail de documentation en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence sûr je veux
dire ce fichage juste la séquence
ouverte ces sources ouvertes ça veut
dire des informations que les uns il
suffit d'ailleurs très bien les mettre
en scène de bien regroupée de faire un
buzz
l'investigation c'est parfois un peu l
enquête vous rajouter des éléments qui
va là sont vos propres sources et vous
emmène au coeur si vous savez vous
mettez des pièces bout à bout et tout
d'un coup ça fait une image et l'image
fait sens
mais en l'occurrence sursis vous savez
cette utilisation de la révolution
digitale et numériques pour un fichage
généralisé qui d'ailleurs est en grande
part pratiquement par les dégâts face et
la protection la question de la
protection des données personnelles est
évidemment que nous sommes réticents
je crois qu'il faut défendre la part
d'opacité de chaque individu s'est pas
seulement défendent la vie privée 1
c'est défendre le fait que nous ne
devons pas être totalement transparent
pour l'état c'est très dangereux parce
que vous savez quand on perd une liberté
quand l'état a réussi à vous enlever une
liberté eh bien il faut des révolutions
est sacrément difficile pour arriver à
la reconquérir
1 les thaïs et un enzyme glouton quand
vous quand il peut nous enlever des
libertés il le fait et regardez ce qui
s'est passé depuis dix ans regardez
comme on a commencé à mettre en cause le
droit de manifester qui est un droit
fondamental le droit de se réunir le
droit de s'exprimer
le droit de s'exprimer au risque de dire
des bêtises mais l'important c'est que
voilà on a des droits fondamentaux après
c'est la justice qui arbitre regardez
comment des décisions étaient prises
dans cette dernière période je pense
notamment au président n'y ait une
simple circulaire de la garde des sceaux
a décidé que l'on pouvait faire passer
la détention
art de 3 mois 6 mois sans audience sans
juge sans contradictoires sans avocat
des gens qui sont en détention
provisoire six repas jugé on sait pas
s'ils vont peut-être être l'axé c'est
bien on décide de continuer à remplir
des prisons au lieu de dire linverse ça
ça a bouleversé et les ordres des
avocats ont protesté je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs si cette mesure a été revu
depuis peut-être on aimait mais vous
voyez bien comment il ya une façon de
décider à notre place qui est encore une
fois autoritaire verticale et qui vous
savez il a essayé de dire autre chose
hier emmanuel macron en nous parlant de
manière subliminale du programme du
conseil national de la résistance il a
parlé des jours heureux c'était le titre
en clandestinité de ce manifeste du cnr
entre communistes gaulliste et toutes
sortes d'autres résistants il nous a
parlé de l'article premier de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme en
disant au fond 1 le premier mérite c'est
celui de son talent et pas celui de la
richesse de la fortune etc
il nous a dit qu'il allait devoir lui le
premier se remettre en cause mais tout
ça ce ne sont que des mots
ce ne sont que des mots et pour que nous
retrouvions confiance il faut d'abord
dire toute la vérité sur les erreurs
passées et il faut surtout changer de
logiciel on ne peut pas être suspendus à
cette parole présidentielle qui décide
tout seul qui décident à notre place et
qui décide sans qu'on sache comment il a
décidé alors deux en formation pour
conclure ce live pour revenir sur les
propos des mâles mâcon ailleurs il faut
savoir que christophe castaner ce matin
déclare à nos confrères de france inter
ce qu'a annoncé le président ce n'est
pas le déconfinement le 11 mai c'est le
confinement
jusqu'au 11 mai c'est un objectif pas
une certitude et jean michel blanquer
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
s'est exprimé je confrères de france 2
ce matin disait que la rentrée
11 mai ne serait pas obligatoire et pas
pour tout le monde en même temps donc ça
c'est important de bien sûr mais on est
au coeur dire que emmanuel macron se
croient ou théâtre il a pris en costume
quel costume de président et il prépare
une intervention comme celle ci
presqu'une demi-heure comme une
performance théâtrale et le théâtre
c'est pas la sincérité
le théâtre c'est un jeu mais c'est pas
un jeu d'être président c'est pas ce
narcissisme c'est c'est pas cette façon
d'endosser un rôle de composition
c'est pas ça qu'on attend et sincèrement
vraiment vous savez ceux et celles qui
suivent médiapart savent que nous on a
toujours refusé ce pouvoir personnel
sous tout président c est ceux qui ont
fondé mediapart savent depuis longtemps
depuis d'autres présidences combien
c'est un crève coeur qui désarme la
démocratie française
mais là on ya encore une fois arrivé au
bout et tout ce que nous décrivons nous
montre encore une fois qu'on doit sortir
de ça ont pu continuer dans ce système
et si on continue dans ce système on va
donner la main à des versions encore
pire de ce système
je le redis encore plus autoritaire
encore plus nationaliste encore plus
vertical encore plus injuste est
vraiment s'il ya quelque chose à faire
dans ce moment où nous sommes confinés
mais où nous pouvons nous parler
communiqué et bien c'est dès maintenant
comme on le fait sur le terrain dans les
entraides entre entre eux
entre travailleurs entre soignant entre
habitants et et c est bien c est
retrouver ce monde des solidarités qui
est encore une fois là la leçon la
première de la nature la nature c'est
pas la compétition c'est pas le cette
version du darwinisme qui est une
version idéologique tiré de la science
de de darwin qui a été un des premiers
naturaliste important non au contraire
le son de la nature celle entraide celle
entraîne la leçon des plantes de la
nature qui est la plus ancienne celle
qui a précédé nos espèces animales et
humaines celles entraide on s'en sort
que parlante raid ne survit que par
l'entr'aide on ne progresse que parlante
raid et c'est vraiment ce que l'on doit
retrouver
merci en tout cas vu merci a répondu à
mes questions on a parlé de beaucoup de
choses on a parlé justement de vos
enquêtes conclu entre eux donc sur le
site de mediapart 1 voilà qui donne
accès libre le week-end dernier mékong
on peut aussi s'abonner bas comme chaque
année on a fait une opération portes
ouvertes pour que mais je rappelle qu'on
n'est pas derrière un mur payant alors
pourquoi on est sur l'abonnement je le
dis nous on ne vit que du soutien de nos
abonnés il n'y a pas de publicité
on n'a pas de fil à la patte comme on
dit en rigolant seules nos lecteurs
peuvent nous acheter il n'y a pas de
mécène qui nous finançons n'a même pas
d'actionnaire on ne touche pas de
subventions on refuse de toucher de
subventions étatiques bref on est
totalement indépendant et ce n'est pas
très cher
d'où le mediapart aujourd'hui et est un
tarif qui qui est vraiment qui est
vraiment incomparable vous avez 12 ans
de mediapart pour soi simplement 11
euros par mois soit 5 euros s'il y a
même un abonnement si vous n'avez pas
les moyens de payer 11 euros par mois 2
5e rouge dit ça pas pour faire une page
de publicité mais pour expliquer
pourquoi ce modèle pour faire ce travail
là ce travail indépendant
et je redis c'est pas un mur le payant
si vous êtes abonnés à mediapart vous
pouvez partager autant d'articles que
vous voulez auprès d' autant d'amis que
vous voulez pouvait leur offrir des
articles vous pouvez parrainer vos amis
pour qu'ils aient un accès libre à
mediapart
beaucoup de contenus de médiapart les
résumés de nos articles toutes les
contributions de nos abonnés sont en
accès libre
bref mediapart n'est pas enfermé dans
une muraille mediapart est un journal
participatif est un journal au service
encore une fois de la société un journal
que ses abonnés ont droit de critiquer
de contester de discuter de bousculer
bref on essaye d'appliquer dans notre
travail
ce que nous reprochons au pouvoir
parfois de ne pas faire ça on vous
remercie en tout cas de mer et la lépi
remercie toutes les personnes qui ont
suivi ce live on vous a proposé en live
comme on peut le faire depuis des années
mais aussi depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire à la rencontre de
médecins de politiques de journalistes
aussi comme c'est le cas avec edwy
plenel aujourd'hui qui est cofondateur à
mediapart pour parler de cette enquête
qui l'ont révélé ces derniers jours sur
la gestion des masques pour ceux qui
sont arrivés en cours de l'ail vous
pourrez voir le replay ses interviews en
live on va continuer de vous les
proposer que ce soit les médecins que ce
soit ceux qui sont aussi à la gestion de
cette crise
on parle notamment de l'extrait du live
qu'on a pu faire et colis de viande
ministre de la santé
on continuera d'essayer d'aller à la
rencontre d'autres ministres d'autres
politiques pour qu'ils puissent nous
donner à bien leur vision de cette crise
sur la sortie de crise sur la suite
aussi parce que on est encore en plein
dedans et on le voit encore avec les
bilans dramatiques au quotidien les
politiques aussi d'opposition qu'on va
aussi aller voir dans l'est dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines pour aller voir leur avis leur
avis sur ce qui se passe maintenant mais
aussi sur la suite
la suite c'est aussi l'occasion vous
pouvez faire vos feedbacks votre tour
vos idées vos critiques vos suggestions
de direct vous avez les messages privés
de la page facebook de brut vous avez
mon
montereau description de ce live qui est
juste au dessus vous pouvez envoyer vos
messages vos retours pour pouvoir bien
voilà nous dire ce qui vous plaît s'il
vous plaît pas quelle question n'aurait
pu poser sur quelles thématiques vous
souhaitez qu'on aborde dans l'est dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
heures
donc n'hésitez pas en tout cas vos
retours sont extrêmement précieux pour
nous pour construire cette forme de
journalisme interactives comme celle
qu'on a pu faire sur ce direct en
prenant en compte et bien vos
commentaires en rebondissant dessus
comme j'essaie de le faire du mieux
possible
durant ce direct et on essaiera est bien
de continuer à le faire dans les
prochains jours je salue notamment
claude fruchet paul qui sont la
programmation à brut et qui travaillent
au quotidien pour qu'on puisse avoir
dans plein de personnes très différentes
qui puisse nous exposer les choses on
espère dans les prochaines heures dans
les prochains jours à avoir un nouveau
médecin chef de service qu'ils puissent
un peu nous faire un point sur la
situation et sur les annonces du
président de la république d'un point de
vue médical parce que c'est important de
pouvoir en parler le lendemain voilà les
mesures qui ont été annoncées
quelle est la réaction d'un point
médical sur tout cela est bien on
essaiera bien évidemment d'en reparler
dans les prochaines heures et dans les
prochains jours en direct et bien les
sujets préparé par la rédaction
my brute également je vous en parle on
vous mettra le lien dans les
commentaires c'est la lettre
d'information vous pouvez recevoir tous
les jours sur vos boîtes mail vous
renseigner juste votre e mail et tous
les jours en fin de journée nous venons
vers vous avec toutes nos publications
sur le coronavirus mais pas que pour
vous informer pour vous donner tous les
éléments sur cette crise sanitaire et
sur le reste de l'actualité parce que le
monde même s'il s'est arrêtée en partie
n'est pas arrêter totalement et il se
passe certaines choses et on essaye
aussi de vous en parler avec toute la
rédaction qui vous prépare ses sujets
donc un grand merci à vous le répète ce
live tout de suite dès que j'appuie sur
le bouton terminé vous pouvez voir le
replay parce que pour beaucoup
vous arrivez en cours de live et voulait
pas forcément au dit bah voila j'ai
loupé le reste vous n'a pas abordé tel
ou tel sujet beaucoup des sujets que
vous évoquez maintenant on les a
abordées dans life précédemment donc le
replay tout de suite je pense qu'on
mettra aussi le live sur youtube en en
archivage aussi donc voilà très très
bonne journée à vous prenez soin de vous
et de vos proches on ne répétera jamais
assez
surtout dans ces périodes là et puis
encore un grand merci à vous monsieur
pénale pour ce direct et d'avoir
consacré du temps à brut pour revenir
sur cette enquête qu'on a évoqué dans ce
live et que vous pouvez retrouver sur
mediapart.fr très bonne journée à tous
et à toutes et à très bientôt
ciao